There are many people who say that if you want to learn practical Japanese, you shouldn't use anime to
study,
but I personally
don't think anime is as practical as teaching materials.
What were you
doing before? Yes, you
were using Twitter.  It's being
used, isn't it?
Serial
Experiments Rain
is definitely more practical than Genki. Now that AI is
spreading, the next thing that's said to spread
is VR.  If you do, you'll have an AI girlfriend."
No, it'll be a certainty, so
Chobits is more useful than Japaneseypeople. Also, Saori
's
romantic girlfriend will eventually
integrate with the general artificial intelligence of the Internet and you.  But
when you don't know how to deal with it,
of course,
Ghost in the Shell
is a better reference than the door.  Using it
should lead to more practical Japanese.By
the way, if you already spend part of your life in the Metaverse, you'll
find SAO useful, but I
can't really recommend it.